- You got two
seats at Portillo's.
Michelle Obama,
Jordan and Oprah:
Who're you eating with?
- Ahh, I'm dropping Jordan, man.
- [Channing Frye:] Ooh!
- [Candace Parker:] No Portillo's for Jordan.
- [Frye:] Ow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We're here at L'Angolo
Estate, where I found out
that wine wasn't just
something I wanted
to share with my
family but something I
wanted to share with the world.
It's here that we created
Chosen Family Wines.
Well, guys, we have an amazing,
amazing day in store for you,
with some drinking, some wine,
talking hoops with the WNBA
champion, a two-time
NCAA champion,
Defensive Player of the
Year, five-time All-Star,
five-time Russian
League Champion,
four-time Russian Cup,
one-time EuroLeague Champion.
And, I mean, if we could look
at all these accolades,
we would have to
do this all day.
Well, I just want to say
thanks to Candace Nicole Parker
for being here on "Full Bodied."
As the wines get
darker, the questions
are gonna get deeper.
First of all, we have to
pop open this champagne.
I knew you were good.
I did not know you
were on God-level good.
Let's cheers to
you and everything
that you've accomplished.
What I've seen over
the last few years,
not only from what
you have done,
from what a lot of
other powerful women
have done in the NBA
and around sports,
is change the
culture of how we
see women in the
workplace, how we see women
as mothers and as professionals.
And overall, you're
just cool as shit.
- [Laughing]
- [Frye:] So, you know, cheers to you.
I think the first thing that
I want to talk about is 2016.
- [Commentator:] The LA Sparks have
slain the mighty Lynx.
- [Commentator:] Candace Parker!
- 2016.
Man, it's interesting that
you're talking about champagne
at this point in time,
because I remember
I got some Dom Perignon in 2008
- Ooh.
- that was given to me after we
won the NCAA championship.
And they handed it
to me, and I decided
I wasn't going to open
it until we won a WNBA
championship.
- OK.
- You know, in 2008.
So this was back in 2008.
I'm thinking, like, yo, you know, maybe
one, maybe two years,
maybe three, maybe four.
- [Laughing]
- Ended up being a
whole lot longer
- [Laughing]
- than one, maybe two years.
- Here's something
that I didn't know.
You played the end of your
rookie season pregnant.
How in God's green Earth did
you play at an elite level
not only taking
care of yourself
but obviously taking care
of your healthy, amazing,
wonderful daughter
at the same time?
- Honestly, I thought
I was just tired.
You know, I had played a year straight.
I had played ever since the year
before, with USA basketball,
and then played all
of college and then
went straight to WNBA season.
And then, from WNBA season,
I went to the Olympics,
and then back to WNBA.
And after the
Olympics, which is when
I was pregnant with my daughter,
I just thought I was tired.
So we pushed
through that season,
and, you know, it didn't end the way that
we wanted it to on the court,
in terms of we lost in
the Western Conference Final
on a last-second shot, but
that's for another drink.
- [Laughing] Listen, we got sips.
- At the same time, you know, winning
Rookie of the Year and MVP,
I wasn't really
thinking about that.
- Right.
- It was, I was disappointed at
the end of the year,
and then I got this
amazing surprise.
Anybody that knows me,
I've always wanted to be a mom.
And, honestly, it couldn't
have come at a better time.
It was at the early
stage of my career where
now my daughter and I
have grown up together.
I don't remember
basketball before her.
I mean, if you think about it, it
wasn't being pregnant playing.
It was coming back
after pregnancy,
to me, that was hard.
- Right.
- She was six weeks old when I
came back and stepped up out
on the court and played
for the first time.
- My wife got pregnant.
It took me six months to
get back to the court.
[Both laughing]
I think that needs
to get talked more.
About how powerful that is,
that you guys are not just
sitting on the side.
And not that that's
wrong, but you guys
are still continuing
to play the sport that
is so hard, that is so
physical, that is so daunting,
at an elite level
and also growing
another amazing human
being inside you.
- Cheers.
Thank you, Channing.
To completely throw this off,
since I've given you 10 minutes
of compliments, you've got
two seats at Portillo's.
Michelle Obama,
Jordan and Oprah:
Who're you eating with?
- Ahh,
I'm dropping Jordan, man.
I'm dropping Jordan.
- [Frye:] Ooh!
- No Portillo's for Jordan.
- Ow.
[Both laughing]
I think, honestly,
Jordan and Michelle Obama
would both give up their seat
if I picked either one of them
over Oprah.
So I think that's it.
- [Laughing]
On this next wine.
This was new to me in
the last few years.
- OK.
So it's a Chablis.
What I know from white wine is
the old-school, big, buttery,
oaky.
You just take wet,
buttered popcorn.
- Mmhmm.
- Right?
That's what my
parents grew up on.
That was my image of chardonnay.
But we picked this for you,
because Chablis was made
from the exact same grape,
100 percent chardonnay.
But instead of months in
oak, it's made in steel vats.
It's in a different
environment but still has
a legendary, classic taste.
On the same note, without you
leaving L.A. to go to Chicago,
we would never get to
witness your next step,
the evolution, this Chablis.
So I wanted to
share this with you
and let you know how
excited I am of your future.
- Thank you.
I'm gonna open mine, though.
- So, as you're
opening that, I think
I've been around
more Chicago people
than any other
city in the world,
because I played for Zeke,
played with Quentin Richardson,
played with Eddy Curry.
But what is it like
to be from Chicago?
- Well, first, I wanna,
I wanna say, because I've
gotten a lot of flak lately,
- [Laughing]
- where I don't claim to be from Chicago.
I claim to be from Chicagoland.
And I make this very clear.
- Ooh, that's good.
- That I am from the suburbs.
Proud to be from Naperville.
- [Frye:] Yeah, suburban commando.
- Graduated high school
from Naperville Central.
But I graduated on the court
from the Chicagoland area.
- Yeah.
- I played near, far,
downtown, western suburbs.
You talk about north,
south, everywhere
in the State of Illinois.
You know, it's just a different
breed of people.
- Mmm.
- And when you're
playing basketball,
just, it's a different following.
I know some of it is
home, but just all
about support and following.
There's so many
people that I run
into that are from Naperville or
from the Chicagoland area that
have followed me
my entire career.
- Right.
And to say that that hasn't
been a part of my journey?
- No.
- It just was only right
to go back home.
So I do believe in full
circle and things like that.
But I think it was
just the right time, you know?
To go back to what
I'm used to and go
back to where I'm from. To end.
Because, you know, Channing,
the end is near.
It's coming.
- Ooh, listen, the end
ain't too bad, girl.
You could do these
shows with me.
- It's coming.
I'm ready to do this
more on the regular.
- If I think about all the Chicago
players that have come out,
No. 1 is a loyalty
to that city and a loyalty
to pass on, like, the
tradition of griminess.
Every Chicago player is willing
to, No. 1, throw hands,
and No. 2, elbow you if it
costs winning the game, right?
- I think it's a little
bit of everything,
because, you know, I think Illinois as a
whole has a style and a brand
of basketball.
For me, personally,
I think I'm fluid.
I mean, you said throw hands.
I'll definitely do that.
But at the same time,
- I've seen you elbow
many a people.
[Both laughing]
- Oh, don't tell them about all
those times on set, Channing.
Nah, but the versatility,
I think, is a big part,
just being effective.
But I don't want
it to get confused.
Like, we're extremely skilled,
versatile, fluid.
- Yeah, oh, yeah.
- But I would take
our five any day.
- Oh, for sure.
You were one of the first
women Adidas athletes.
There have not been a lot
of women's signature shoes.
Do you think that's gonna
start coming around?
And how can that culture
change where, you know, my daughter can
get her first Candace Parkers?
- Well, here's the first
and foremost, Channing.
I've been fortunate enough
to be with partnerships
for a long time.
It's really important to me
to do something authentic,
and loyalty is huge
to me, honestly.
And that's why it
was so difficult
for me to leave the Sparks.
- Right, right.
- Because usually when
I start something,
I've always been
taught to finish.
And I did.
My contract was up,
so I was able to go.
But the same with Adidas.
I have been three stripes
basically since my junior year
in high school.
I've been in Adidas since,
- Ooh, fire.
- the first Kobes that
came out, the moon boots.
- Oh, the moon joints.
- I've been in Adidas that long.
It's always been a
part of what I'm doing,
and I've always had a strong
relationship with them.
So when I got out of college
after being four years
of Adidas at Tennessee—at the
time, Tennessee was Adidas—
it was a no-brainer.
To be honest with you,
it is important for me
to make a shoe
that's a signature
and represented by a woman.
- Right.
But at the same,
I've gone into Adidas
and carved out this
niche for all genders.
I want little boys to be
OK with wearing my shoes,
and so that's been a
huge effort for me.
- Are they gonna have some
tight colorways or what? Listen.
- We got you, Channing.
It's in the works.
- OK.
And a lot of it was
sizing issues, too,
like making things
gender-neutral,
- Right. Right, right.
but making them in men's sizes.
And there had been no, up until this
point, there had been
women that had signature shoes.
You talk about Lisa
Leslie, Sheryl Swoopes.
- Right, right.
- But there hadn't been
women that had had
signature shoes in men's sizes.
And so that was important
to me, was to make more
of a gender-neutral so that we
introduce the fact that it is
OK to then dream about, you know, wearing
different shoes and different
collections, similar to like
you're seeing Beyoncé.
You're seeing a lot of men
that are rocking Ivy Park.
- OK.
- And so I think it's similar
to like that kind of thing,
where it's OK to
look up to women
and see women in
leadership positions.
And I think it starts with shoe
companies and organizations
and your partnerships putting
women out there like that.
- Right.
Speaking of that, because you
helped my transitions better
than I could, we're going
to go to this third wine.
So Stag's Leap Wine Cellars
are known for their Napa Cabs.
That's pretty much all
I drink, are Napa Cabs.
Gotten into a little
bit of the French wine.
- Burgundies?
- Burgundies, yes.
I have a lot of friends
that are French,
and so they're getting
me into their wine.
I've kind of been heavy into wine,
probably for the last four
years, I would say.
I have to admit,
I was in my 20s, and
not to throw shade.
I'm not throwing
shade at any wine.
But I was more of
the sweet, Moscato.
- Ooh.
- In the shopping aisle, like,
give me the Cupcake.
- Uh-oh.
- You know, the sweetest wine.
- The little kangaroo, huh?
- I was one of those in my 20s.
- [Laughing]
- And when I hit about
28, 29 years old,
I had a really good friend that
really got heavy into wine.
- Yeah.
- And I'm very coachable,
so show me what you like
and tell me about it.
I'm gonna research it.
I'm gonna do all that stuff.
And Santa Barbara's
right up the road.
- Oh, yeah.
- Napa's not too far.
So I just started
taking trips and going
to vineyards and wineries, and
I've really fallen in love.
And like you said,
the question I
used to ask when I was early on
was: What's your favorite wine?
- Yeah.
- But really, it depends.
Like you said, it
could be a $10 bottle,
and it's shared over a
dinner that's memorable.
And so, honestly, I started
keeping important corks.
- Oh, yeah, you got the bug.
- So I got the bug. But I got
some important corks in here
of nights, and I write on 'em.
- Oh, dude, that's the best.
- Business deals, times, you know
I got a 2016 cork in
here where
- Oh.
- that was when we won the championship.
- That's tight.
- I've really kind of taken to it.
- One last, last,
last, last thing. OK?
This is a fun game.
It's called "Fill in the Grape."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Do you wanna play the
game, or do you wanna
say whatever you wanna say?
- I wanna play the
game and I wanna
to say whatever I'm gonna say.
[Laughing]
I want both.
- Oh, perfect, boss.
There's five categories: TheLady Vols, Slam Dunk Contest,
Your 2016 'Ship, Music and Kicks.
- Oh, wow.
- We're going to go through each category in whatever order
you want.
If you can't get it right,
you gotta take a sip.
- All right.
- OK.
Which one do you
want to go first?
- I'll do Kicks.
- What shoe did you
have on when you
became the second player in
WNBA history to dunk in a game?
- I remember the shoes.
They were the Adidas, like with
the little strap, with the strap on 'em.
- [Frye:] The Adidas with
the strap on 'em.
- Were they the Ace Commanders?
- No.
- I'mma just drink
cuz I wanna drink
cuz it's good.
- The Adidas Piranha 3.0.
- Yeah, I didn't get that.
I'll go Music.
- What was Jay-Z's
No. 1-selling album
of all time?
"Volume 2... Hard Knock
Life" or "Volume 3...
Life and Times of S. Carter"?
- "Hard Knock Life."
- Ooh, correct.
I guess I'll drink,
because that is right.
- I'll drink with you, Channing.
- Thank you.
So Slam Dunk Contest.
What was your final slam dunk
score after the first round?
- I know I got like one nine, I think.
But I'm going to just
drink because I don't
- Ooh.
- I don't know the score.
- 145.
- OK, so I got a couple of nines.
- Lady Vols, here we go.
Can you name the six Lady
Vols who have their basketball
jerseys retired?
- Daedra Charles, myself, Holly
Warlick, Tamika Catchings,
Chamique Holdsclaw, and...
- It's BG, is the initials.
- Bridgette Gordon!
How could I forget her?
- There we go.
- I know Bridgette Gordon.
But I'll drink for that
cuz I got it wrong.
- Last question.
2016, how many rebounds
did you and Nneka each
have in Game 5 of your
2016 Championship?
- 12.
- Ooh, ahh.
I can't remember how many
points I had in my last game,
and that was only
three years ago.
- Man, 2016. That's a, that's a memory.
- Yeah, I'll say this.
I'm going back to the champagne.
2016 got your boy having
a hangover already.
- [Laughing]
- Thank you so much for coming.
Anything else you want to say?
You have the most
interesting life,
which is shocking, because I
thought you were very boring.
- [Laughing]
But you are amazing. [Laughing]
- Well, Channing,
first and foremost, I
want to say thank you so much.
You know, I love that we're expanding
as to what athletes
are and considered to be.
I love that you're doing this.
Getting into wine, I
realize, like you've said,
not everything is the
most expensive bottle.
It doesn't have to be.
I do have expensive tastes,
so some of those are, you know,
I like Staglin.
I like Colgin.
- Ooh, Staglin.
Fire.
- I had a Screaming
Eagle a couple
- Dang!
- a couple weeks ago for a
friend's birthday.
- Oh!
- That was probably the
most expensive bottle
I've ever had in my life.
- Ooh, you've got
that money money.
- No.
I didn't pay for it, trust me.
- You going back home.
Do they have state
taxes in Chicago?
- Oh, trust me, I
didn't pay for it.
- OK, OK. $FREE-99, right up my alley.
- Keep the corks.
Write down goals or
write down memories.
Write down who was at the
dinner. Because it's really
a cool keepsake
that I've started.
And, you know, I hope at some point to share
a bottle in person with you.
You bring your favorite
and I bring my favorite,
and we'll get this thing going.
- Well, listen.
I'll just bring my wine.
- Sounds amazing.
- Awesome.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you, Channing.
I'm going to finish
this, though.
- You're a savage.